[Musique]
c'est au oui allô bonjour alors gogo
beach alors ok je te vois tu en étais
loin toi je tente le toit attends moi
aussi je tente le toit et mais je trouve
que balcon juin non non c'est un terrain
je suis bloqué dans les airs mais non tu
rigoles mes potes avaient tout état
faute et c'est reparti à sanaa fait
c'est à saint luc a aujourd'hui on y va
on dira le début d'un mauvais oeil times
elle marchera pas d'être derrière ce
faux je te disais un jour que tu
t'entends à we know vous avez macron je
ressemble à bach rond qu'est ce qu'elle
fait
au début tu comme une accusation que je
me suis fait agresser la peau [ __ ] la
dégustation se fait cette année rue du
maine par exemple manger un peu sauvage
mais que j'ai envie de me gifler j'ai
envie de mettre des claques et de me
couper la mèche haute est mon ami on en
tremble à la pesanteur wyeth et du coup
j'ai eu ma petite vengeance on voit ta
tête quand tu as vraiment 14 en quoi
c'est très drôle
bien sûr bien sûr on peut gagner face à
pascal qui est pas gagné je pleure je
pleure pas parce que je vous ai fait
déçu je pleure parce que j'ai fait tu as
sûrement raison on était supposé aller
chez un ami et faire la fête et me
laisser seul comme ça peut-être qu'elle
va nous proposer de venir du coup tu en
fais pas j'ai mon téléphone
[Musique]
cette vidéo c'est un coup de couteau
permanent dans le coeur quoi mais fait
qu'ils sont pas placés au coeur regarde
ça c'est vrai c'est vrai ça je me serais
je laisse tomber j'ai une question
ouais c'est une femme ou un homme c'est
une chose atari sans eau et rochers
devant là ok je le vois je veux voir à
temps mais qu'attend j'ai une grosse
chine toi je tente une groupe alstom
avait sorti andy roddick à gauche par
michael jansen gros faut que tu sors tu
obtiens mecachrome quand j'entends les
top 12 ans
[Musique]
non nous enlever nos pas réussi à me
défendre est ce qu'on est destiné à
devenir des tables basses
[Musique]
au bout il ya des formes qui vont nous
arriver dessus va falloir les skis mais
voilà et c'est tout ça en rythme avec
une musique je peux choisir la musique
on cherche un moyen c'est la meilleure
vidéo de ma chaîne youtube c'est sur
celle ci aussi
et bah du coup c'est le hockey sous
l'eau mais comment tu peux faire du rock
et soul aux [ __ ] on sera là bientôt
ça va c'est ici pas foule en fête
oui j'aime pas foule là où le bruit pour
nos champions gens des petites
c'est quoi ces deux forces pour retirer
le givre sur ta voiture le matin la
mecque à regarder ça il fait plutôt bas
canada tuba et je te faire sport vers
les mecs on dirait que tu connais même
pas ton équipe tu avais tu as qu'il fait
bien des segments qui avait vu deux
chansons recadrer ses jambes et un
bagage et de monza car la russie sur ce
que j'avais je laisse moi on fait le
point ce qui ne va pas mais tu peux
utiliser est tournée mais quelques
caméras ça abusé osaka qui attend le mec
il a dit au sac à osaka c'est une très
grosse ville au japon avec du coup du
côté mais je me suis dit c'est du chien
poney japonais un peu un peu danois
quand même tu vois c'est bien évidemment
du danois avec le coeur mais qu'il faut
faire en fait un respect pour sortir ton
pénis mais attends mais c'est quoi ce
jeu en fait aux lecteurs français
ouais vous aimez bien tout le monde
n'aime pas ce parti du tout face au
petit poucet norman thavaud je vais être
apte et non le batteur ton visage
on dirait un chameau merci niaux on ne
fera plus à mettre vidéo ensemble tu me
sens pas technitoit t'es cuit dans
l'espace buzz
oh merde je l'entends d'embrouillés
toolbar qu'est ce qu'il fait qu'est ce
que c'est quoi cet endroit mais tout
allait bien jusqu'à ce que tu fasses a
nommé des loges dans les smart et des
lettres
pardon non je veux juste aider pardon
mais plus tard c'est contagieux ou kuala
je me tenais mais je crois que je peux
juste taper je vais t'aider
je suis en train de télé je vais t'aider
je m'étais dis moi rêver au maintien des
prêts à 3 à 2 3 désolé mais tu as
[Musique]
je t'avoue et numériques dvr
une activité ça fait quand même mal de
se faire couper la jambe à la la
qu'est-ce que ça fait mal je sais j'ai
mangé par toujours mon dieu c'est
terrible pour désinfecte valeurs sûres
gros seins ça lui laisse un très large
choix de personnages 50% du duel tu as
dit gros ça veut dire autant
à
babet waouh j'ai pas qu'elle ait choqué
les aztèques merde s'exclamer s'étaient
pas inscrits et une manière un peu un
peu commune de dire oh là là je suis
surpris en fait ça voulait dire oh là là
je suis surpris mais c'était un tour sur
vidéo c'est plus simple est mort la
route historique va pas bien il va bien
ça se mordille elle salue du japon je me
méfie c'est la danse des canards et en
septembre encore c'était son ok ça sur
tes genoux tuvene fait chaud salut c'est
la provence alors squeeze ou six prix
bas cyprien bah voilà comme 58 % des
gens ont dit il pas y passer outre ce
site
ce que je veux dire ma phrase gentille
pour nathalie matte où tu as tu fais ce
que tu as comme info nathalie la réponse
est à l'envers
est ce qu'elle est à l'envers genre
horizontalement ou est ce qu'elle à
l'envers verticalement et
horizontalement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[ __ ] mais tu peux voir la fierté dans
tes yeux cadastre industry s'abstrait ce
mec à ton mec tu vas pas me planter le
palais n'a jamais été aussi peu sera
remis au liban
alors si vous saviez mais ce
dictionnaire a été dirigée par appareil
un gros gros bien que je ne sais pas et
ça veut dire quoi diriger un
dictionnaire et oui les mosellans
on attend à l'impasse qu'on peut pas on
peut pas écrire indique aussi l'arrivée
les gars est-ce que je peux mon affaire
les dès aujourd'hui lol désolé il ya
encore le fonds vert mais qui me tue pas
parce que tu peux pas faire ça tu peux
pas faire tourner dans ta g dire désolé
il ya encore le faire ça ne marche pas
jamais dans la vidéo
[Rires]
[Musique]
toi c'est autocité et mais c'est le seul
mec viril est génial
oui oui je voudrais une photo de la
boule de fort boyard le droit sur le
monde revient sur ses parties de la
boule de foyers alors merci
il est décédé oui c'est bon tu sais
alors devinez devinez devinez
mais je suis en train de pourrir de
l'intérieur
c'est terrible et ça c'est le troisième
une tumeur de france qui rigole pour
deux minutes parce qu'il a pété vivez
votre vie prenez soin de vous n'oubliez
pas qu'on sème tout ce qu'on est en
train carpediem tant pis
[Musique]